you know the World Cup kicked off this
weekend uh I think the World Cup is uh
that's the soccer thing and I don't
follow because I'm I'm more of a sports
fan personally but
and I don't have anything against soccer
I think soccer is a fine hobby you know
for children that is if you want your
children to become communists
um it's a great hobby for communist
children I suppose is what I'm saying I
don't mean any offense by that
um and it's not even the communism of
soccer that I have the biggest problem
with is really it's it's it's mainly
that soccer makes baseball seem
thrilling by comparison which is very
hard to do
but anyway the World Cup did kick off
and uh we talked about last week There's
controversy over the fact that the World
Cup is in Qatar and Qatar is not exactly
known as like the gay rights capital of
the world okay it's not it's it's not
that precisely
um homosexuality is effectively illegal
there or literally illegal and uh this
is in conflict with FIFA that's the
World Cup's governing organization it's
in conflict with with all of the LGBT uh
virtue signaling that they usually do
they so they want to have their woke
cake and eat it too on one hand they
want to advertise themselves as Uber
woke on LGBT stuff but on the other hand
they want to take money from Qatar
and this has led to criticism
and the U.S team addressed the criticism
by covering themselves in Rainbow Flags
head to toe uh they're going to try to
glitter and rainbow themselves out of
this gem although it is kind of
redundant you know all the gay
paraphernalia with soccer
um
because we see that and everyone's like
you're a soccer team we know we get it
but the president of FIFA his name is
Gianni Infantino uh took it a step
further you gave a press conference
defending his decision to send the World
Cup to Qatar and it was uh it was
something I have to say so let's he
starts by by telling us how he feels
what he's feeling and it's well just
listen
very strong feelings I can tell you that
today I feel uh
katari
today I feel
Arab
today I feel African
foreign
gay
today I feel disabled
today I feel
a migrant worker
that is that is uh that's the funniest
thing I've seen in a long time that is
literally something out of the office I
mean that is that I think that's almost
verbatim a speech that Michael Scott
gave on diversity day at the office I
think and he's so proud of himself too
he's he thinks he's saying something
profound he has this look on his face
it's like it's the Kamala Harris look
right it's you know uh where he's he's
sputtering nonsense but but thinks that
he's nailing it and uh perhaps the
greatest lines ever delivered in the
history of public speaking today I feel
gay today I feel disabled
and you know though a short pause before
he said gay like he was having second
thoughts about going this direction but
he already committed to it so he just
went with it and then he felt pretty
good about it uh and then also notice
another thing too
that he said
I feel a migrant worker
he didn't say I feel like a migrant
worker inside that he said I feel a
migrant worker
so this is maybe a confession as well
I have to admit something to you sadly
um I don't have Perfect Skin it's hard
to believe considering how Flawless and
glowing I look on your screen but it's
true I your sweet baby gang cult leader
do get forehead wrinkles dark spots on
occasion under eye bags I came this
realization when I'm a morning my wife
told me that I looked too tired and
Haggard on camera she insisted that I
use her genucel under eye puffiness
cream and uh I couldn't believe how
quickly the bags under my eyes cleared
up sounds too good to be true right it's
not now geniusell skin care is a part of
my daily routine genucel has sold over 1
million products to both men and women
and the reviews speak for themselves
Samantha writes I've used it all over my
face under my eyes and cleared up the
dry flakiness and even reduced my
forehead lines Susan wrote I've been
using genucel for a couple months the
puffiness around my eyes is gone even
the crow's feet and small lines have
disappeared genocell uses a proprietary
base with clinical levels of Botanical
extracts which come together to yield
amazing results genucel products are
natural cruelty free and made in the USA
take advantage of genyourself's early
Black Friday sale going on right now you
can get their most popular products
package for over 70 off you'll get two
months worth of their best sellers plus
their hyaluronic acid serum free with
your purchase go to genucel.com Walsh
and use code Walsh for an extra 10 off
that's genucel.com Welsh
in any case that's not really the part
that I want to focus on that's just uh
that's it's a little bit of uh of
comedic relief
um he then goes on into this rant to
justify FIFA's uh business with Qatar
and this is what he says
we are told many many lessons
from
some Europeans from the Western world
I'm European
actually I am European not just I feel
European
I think for what we Europeans have been
doing in the last 3000 years
around the world we should be
apologizing for next 3000 years
before starting to give moral lessons
to people
Europeans should apologize for the last
3 000 years that's how far back he's
indicting Europeans uh Europeans and
Americans too by extension if we're
going back 3 000 years right so
um and uh he's he's saying
that so it's really what he's really
said the Western World should apologize
for the past three thousand years so
we're going back to uh Aristotle and
before that well before that and
apologizing for what apologizing for
democracy for the concept of human
rights for modern science for modern
medicine for space travel for
electricity
for the fact that the human the human
life expectancy is over the age of 35
like is that what we're apologizing for
because you could thank the Western
World for all that
and much more
basically
almost everything that makes your life
enjoyable and tolerable you can thank
the Western World for so if we're
apologizing for three thousand years
then we're apologizing for all that
now with that said
I would actually agree
that modern westerners
don't have much room to be lecturing
other cultures about anything
so that's the Nuance right if that's
what he was saying it's not what he said
but if you're saying modern westerners
don't
then that part I would have to agree
because we murder our babies here we as
discussed we castrate our children we
sterilize them uh we are utterly
consumed right now tragically sadly
terribly by moral Madness
that's the modern West
which means that we're in no position to
lecture anyone morally on anything I
agree with that but but that's not what
he's talking about
he's bringing the indictment back
Millennia which means that he's saying
we should apologize for just our
existence for for all the good stuff
all the good stuff from the West the
stuff that uh that um we are now
abandoning really
because the West if the West should
apologize for anything
today
the West should apologize for not being
Western enough that is I mean for
abandoning
all that made the West great especially
when it comes to uh moral insights the
moral formation
what was once the wisdom of the West
we've abandoned that
and we are collapsing because of it and
so we're going to apologize for anything
yeah apologize for that
but He suggests we apologize for that
very foundation for the foundations of
the West if he wants to go back 3000
years
or else maybe he's talking about you
know slavery and Conquest
because that happened in the west
historically
and it that's true it did
but of course it happened everywhere
else in the world too and for longer
so when it comes to issues like slavery
racism that sort of thing
can you name a region of the world that
has a better record with that stuff than
the West does
the West is in no position to lecture
about that well who's who's in a better
position
what part of the world when it comes to
if if he's speaking specifically about
Conquest slavery racism
what region of the world has had a
better track record
outside of the western world
and it doesn't exist
it doesn't it doesn't even come close to
existing
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow God's
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]